in the last video we saw the two chair
shapes or the two chair configurations
of just plain vanilla cyclohexane we're
equally stable there was nothing that
would imply that this is more stable
than that or vice versa
but we want to do in this video is
address what happens if instead of just
a pure cyclohexane what if we added a
methyl group to it and so instead of
just a cyclohexane let's think about a
methylcyclohexane and so we know what
our what to do when we're naming things
so a methylcyclohexane methylcyclohexane
will look like that look like we'll have
a hexagon here this is the way we've
been drawing it historically we've been
drawing it just like that and then it'll
have a methyl group and you could
literally just draw a methyl group like
this or maybe like this and by
implication you have a carbon here
essentially a ch3 group here and of
course you have another hydrogen bonded
here now if you were to draw this methyl
group in kind of three dimensions like
this it would look just like our
different chair positions before but
instead of this H being just an H we
could make this entire methyl group so
we could turn this ch3 right here so
this let me draw it out in a different
color we could make this carbon that has
implicitly has three hydrogen's on it so
this is a ch3 group that is a methyl
group that's right there we could turn
one of these we could substitute one of
these hydrogen's with it and then this
would be one of the shapes of this
methylcyclohexane so ch3 let me write it
down just to practice our naming so this
is methyl methyl cyclo hexane now in
this this is one of their chair
positions and then if this were to flip
down and the other side were to flip up
the other chair position would take this
methyl group from being in an axial
position and it would put it in an
equatorial position so this is the same
group right here let me put a circle
around it it's a whole group that's the
ch3 now the question we want to answer
in this video is one of these two
configurations going to be more stable
now you might just be able to eyeball it
looking at this diagram say hey when
we're in this when we're in the position
where the methyl group is in the
axial position it's going to be closer
to all of these other carbons over here
closer to their electron clouds maybe it
has higher potential energy
maybe it'll want to spring away and if
that was what you're guessing or what
you're kind of eyeballing you'd be right
because in this position this methyl is
much further away from all of the stuff
out here so they'll be less I guess you
can consider it electron cloud electron
cloud crowding if you will now to see
that a little bit more clear I want to
do a a what we call it as a double
Newman diagram and really that's the
whole motivation of this video to kind
of expose you to that a Newman diagram
isn't just useful for simple things like
a butane or an ethane you can actually
do it with cyclical rings and to do the
Newman diagram let me number these
carbons so we could number them like
this so this this is carbon one two
three four five six and you don't have
to call this one methyl cyclohexane
because what you always have whenever
you have only one group attached to the
ring you implicitly start the numbering
at the at the carbon that the group is
attached so that is the one carbon over
here this is the one carbon two three
four five six and over here once again
is the one carbon two three four five
six now what I want to do is draw a
Newman draw two Newman projections and
both of them will involve well actually
I'll draw four but you'll see what I'm
talking about in a second so the first
Newman projection I'm going to start at
this carbon right that carbon right over
there so let's think about what that
would look like so we're at the front
we're staring straight on to that carbon
so this carbons in the front this carbon
over here this carbon carbon number two
is in the back so let me label this this
is carbon number one that we're looking
head-on now right in the axial position
you have that methyl group so let me
draw that so in the axial position in
the axial position you have that methyl
group right over there and then in the
equatorial position right here you have
this hydrogen so let me draw that so you
have this hydrogen and then over here
this bond right over here this gets us
to another ch2 group so let me draw that
like this so that gets us to another
ch2 that's a ch2 right there right or
maybe I should Circle it like this this
whole thing is a ch2 so it's bonded to
the carbon but the carbon has two
hydrogen's on it and this is actually
carbon number six so this is the front
now if we're staring straight and carbon
number two is right behind it let me
draw carbon number two I'll do it in
this blue color so carbon number two
that bigger circle now carbon number two
what's going on over there
it has a hydrogen in the axial position
going straight down it has a hydrogen in
the axial position going straight down
this hydrogen right over there and then
it has a another hydrogen going
equatorial so this green hydrogen right
here is going equatorial it looks like
that and then it connects to carbon
number three which is another ch2 it has
two hydrogen's branching off of it so
this right here so this this in front we
have carbon number one in the back we
have carbon number two let me color code
it a little better Carbon number two and
then carbon number two branches off two
so if you think of this branch right
here you think of that branch right here
that's carbon number two branching off
to carbon number three or ch3 right
there let me do that in a new color so
this is a actually ch2 group that's a
ch2 this is a carbon it has two
hydrogen's right so this is a ch2 this
is carbon number three right this is
carbon number three right there and then
that goes then and actually I'll pause
there what I'll do now is I'll draw
another axial another Newman projection
but for this Newman projection we'll be
looking straight on we'll be looking
straight on our carbon number five our
carbon number five right here we're
going to see we're going to form a ring
because this the first Newman projection
we just did essentially covers this bond
this bond is sitting straight into the
screen the way I did it right now carbon
number two is directly behind carbon
number one so I guess the opposite side
of the Ring is five to four if you look
at here one two is there and then five
to four is just like that so you can
imagine when we're doing the Newman
projections we're looking straight on
here
the left Newman projection we're going
to look straight in that direction on
the right Newman projection so if we
have carbon number five in front if we
have carbon number five in front what
are its bonds going to look like well
it's going to bond to carbon number six
over I'd over here so we can make this
this right let me do that in a different
color this right here this bond right
here is this bond right here to that
same ch2 that our first Newman
projection bonded to and then he's going
to he's going to have two hydrogen's I
haven't drawn them here let me draw them
just so you can see them
I'm going to have two hydrogen's one in
an axial position and one in an
equatorial position it's hard to see now
but he's going to have one hydrogen
axial and one in an equatorial position
and then in the back we're going to draw
carbon number four and carbon number
four I will do in this green color so
carbon number four or actually well yeah
I'll do carbon number four in that green
color and this is really just an
exercise in visualization that's why I
wanted to do it with you so carbon
number four has an axial hydrogen so it
has a hydrogen pointing straight down
that hydrogen is that hydrogen it has an
equatorial hydrogen going out like that
and then it bonds to carbon number three
so this bond right here is this bond
just like that so what do we see
immediately when we put when we draw
this chair position when our when our
methyl group is in the axial position
what do we see methyl methyl in axial
position we see that it's go SHhhh or
gosh I don't know the best way to
pronounce it it's only sixty degrees
away from this from carbon number three
this is only sixty degrees our dihedral
angle you know when you when you use a
Newman projection this is only a a sixty
degree angle it's sixty degree angle it
is gautsche to carbon number three it is
gautsche to carbon number three so maybe
they're crowding each other a little bit
let's compare it to the situation where
our methyl group is equatorial where the
carbon that it's attached to is on the
down part of the chair let's see what
that Newman projection looks like so
same thing
same thing let me scroll over to the
right a little bit so this is this
configuration and it's in equilibrium
it's in equilibrium with this
configuration right here we'll do the
exact same exercise carbon number 1 but
now carbon number 1 and carbon number
one right here the axial the the the
hydrogen is now actual and it's pointing
straight down let me draw that so we
have a hydrogen pointing straight down
now hydrogen's pointing now down and now
the ch3 is in is in a is in a equatorial
position which you can see more clearly
on this and over here so you have a ch3
the methyl group is right there and now
this bond this bond to carbon number six
will look like this
so it will look like this so you have a
ch2 this is number six right over there
and now if we were to go to back if we
were to go to the carbon number two in
back which we had done in the blue color
before so I'll do it in the blue color
again carbon number two in black it has
a hydrogen in the axial position going
straight up that's that hydrogen right
there has a hydrogen going straight up
it has another hydrogen over here and
then it bonds to carbon number three in
the back so ch3 or ch2 over here so this
guy is the same thing as this guy but
now we've flipped configurations so he
bonds to that guy in the back and now we
do the Newman diagram looking straight
on to carbon number five or looking
actually straight on to right Carbon
number five so we're going to look
straight in so we're looking straight in
this direction for this Newman
projection now we're gonna look straight
in this direction for our other Newman
projection so carbon number five carbon
number five if we draw it in the front
it actually I haven't have I haven't
drawn it here but it has a hydrogen the
axial position and then it has a
hydrogen in the equatorial position so
carbon number five if we look at this
and this isn't this is really III if
you're getting a little stressed out
about this because it's a little hard to
understand you might want to re-watch
this is really just a
an example of visualization so I really
hope this isn't confusing you if you
find this really daunting this isn't
going to really trip you up in the left
rest of organic chemistry but if you
can't get it it's even better it'll be
that much better at visualizing some of
these molecules so if we look straight
on in carbon number five we have a
hydrogen in the axial position coming
straight down hydrogen in the axial
position coming straight down it is
bonded it is bonded carbon number five
is bonded to carbon number six which is
right over which is right over there so
let me make it very clear so this bond
right here now I want to do a different
color this bond right here is the same
thing as this one this is a really good
way to if you can do this then your
brain is pretty good at translating
between Newman projections and these
kind of seat diagrams that we have up
here so this is this bond this axial
hydrogen this axial hydrogen is this
axial hydrogen and then we have another
hydrogen we have this hydrogen right
here which would be that like that and
then in behind it you have carbon number
four carbon number four is it's like
that so carbon number four draw a circle
it has a hydrogen in its axial position
another hydrogen like that and then it
bonds to carbon number three so this was
number three right here so just like
that so what do we see about this methyl
group here in this situation this methyl
group is anti it's you know there's two
ways to think about it it's dihedral
angle versus carbon number versus carbon
number three is now 180 degrees over
here it was gosh it was sixty degrees it
was dihedral angle to carbon number
through sixty degrees now it's 180
degrees so it's much further and now
it's dihedral angle to the carbon number
six is also it's also 120 degrees so in
this situation where our methyl group is
equatorial it's not its axial here its
equatorial here when we jumped back down
because notice it's parallel the bond is
parallel to parts of the Ring in this
situation we are farther away from the
other methyl groups there's less
crowding and so this is a more stable
situation so you could say it is anti is
an anti configuration configure a
configuration relative to carbon number
three while over here it was gauche to
carbon number three i don't know if i'm
saying it's go chicago which i don't
know the best way to pronounce it so in
this case there's less crowding this is
more stable lower potential and lower
potential energy more stable so hope you
found that interesting this was really a
way just an exercise in being able to go
from this visualization to kind of this
double Newman diagram and if it makes it
any easier the way you could think about
it is we're kind of viewing we're
viewing in this Newman diagram right
here where this carbon number six is
this carbon number six this ch2 is this
one back there so when we're looking at
it from this we're kind of looking at
this this hexane ring from this
direction we see this in front this is
this and we see that and back that is
that over here same thing we're looking
at it we're looking at it directly we're
looking at it directly from we're
looking at it directly from this
direction we see this guy on top is over
here and this guy on the bottom is over
here so hopefully that helps your
visualization a little bit